all right
here we go
riffing with Griffin it's Wednesday
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffing
with Griffin
live once again let's see today I saw
Indiana Jones I want to tell you my
Indiana Jones history
um what I thought about the movie
there's a tiny purse that's being sold
it's so ridiculous bunch of tech news
bunch of different stories broken roller
coasters weird stuff on the internet and
100 me so ladies and gentlemen welcome
back
[Music]
again
yeah everybody
all right welcome back to riffing with
Griffin uh we added once again uh live
from the Griffin with Griffin Studios
which is my place
welcome back y'all
um excuse me appreciate everybody that's
here welcome chat I see you guys in the
chat on YouTube live thank you very much
for being here so you know make sure you
subscribe all the YouTube people you can
subscribe and hit the notifications so
you get the notifications every week
when I go live sometime on Wednesday I
should be more consistent but it is what
it is uh you can also be a YouTube
member too you know that that's helpful
too if you want to support the show
so thank you for doing that twitch you
know listen twitch you want to be a
twitch follower a game every single day
Eric Griffin gaming but also on Eric
Griffin gaming
I'm gonna do live spoilers which I'm
gonna do after this episode so I told
you last week I wanted to do a whole
spoilers for Black Mirror so I can so I
could just completely talk about it so
I'm gonna do that for just my twitch
subscribers live so if you go to Twitch
you'll be able to see like three or four
minutes of it and then it's gonna cut
off for you you have to be a subscriber
to watch the whole thing and then it's
gonna go up on also patreon so if you
this is going to be some of my new
patreon content It's Gonna Be Live
spoilers well not live but you know what
I mean I could go into detail without
worrying about people that's just one of
the things that I'm gonna be doing on my
patreon so today after this episode I'm
going live again on air Griffin gaming
to uh
talk about
um I'm gonna go into detail all the
episodes of uh Black Mirror and and I
might even even do a little Indiana
Jones too because just go over the story
what I thought of it you know so I don't
have to worry about like people going be
like stop spoiling stuff Griffin so I
appreciate you guys uh that are are for
coming and being here and uh today's
episode is brought to you by doordash
door Dash
um where is it love me some Dash
um doordash download the doordash app
and enter code rwg summer for 50 off
your next door Dash order subjects to
change terms apply that's riffing with
Griffin summer rwg summer one word for
50 off up to a ten dollar value when you
spend 15 or more on your next door dash
pass order doordash
so thank you doordash for being a
sponsor of Griffin with Griffin um where
are we at now what's up y'all
what is up
um thanks for being here you know I know
you guys if you watch the the podcast
last week I I said some some news
you know I know Rachel wants to be a
part of the thing but it's like yeah now
can we just
Rachel's pregnant okay
you normally don't do this this early
but I just
it's not even early but it's just like
going through the the
I want to go through the process with
you guys that support me on with Griffin
because it's it's a lot you know it's a
lot of stuff you know I'll have Rachel
on because she's been really sick and
like she's gonna feeling better looking
better and you know she'll come on and
talk about it but we're still at like a
precarious stage you know it's like man
it's harder to get pregnant than people
think and there's a lot of things to
worry about so we had like a six week
appointment then we had that ultrasound
and we heard the heartbeat and I was
like amazed and I was like oh my God
this is crazy that this is a life for me
and then it was like then we had this
eight week appointment it was like
things are looking good you know and
they're like all right well you know you
have to get the next appointment you
know uh then we'll start you know they
would take blood tests and it's like uh
you know it's like to find out any
genetic stuff right and you're like oh
wow what if there's something right
that's always on your mind and then we
just had an appointment today we had
just like 10 week appointment and then
the the the the doctor that um the
ultrasound ladies like super funny
French woman you know she was like
joking with us and stuff and she's like
oh your baby you know the baby's big and
it's like you know whatever stage we're
at
you know just like whatever stage you're
at it's like she's like everything looks
great you know but it's like you know
it's like one of these things where you
get excited and then you're like okay
and then they're like but the next thing
is that we're gonna be looking for
defects and down syndrome and all this
kind of stuff and so I get that's why
people like normally they like they wait
you know but like I'm very open and I
just thought like this process is
interesting so everybody keep your
fingers crossed you know
that's like hope like I'm not I'm not
having a sad podcast in four weeks you
know what I mean which is like what you
know but things are looking good right
now everything is
um exciting you know
it's like you know you know what I mean
we're at 10 weeks four days looking at a
January baby and it's just like
you know and then when Rachel's feeling
her up you know feeling good I'm gonna
have her we'll sit down and her and I
will go over it in more detail but you
know
that's where I'm at right now you know
it's very
it's it's very interesting process that
you go through that's why I thought I
thought that that
the Kardashians
like her having this sign
at his at his show like guess what I'm
pregnant it's like nah you first of all
you 44. so there's no way he don't know
every step of the way
what's going on with you getting
pregnant
it's such a like ridiculous like anybody
that's dealt with this knows that isn't
the first time he found out about that
you know what I mean it's like what are
you talking about this thing is so
so crazy so
um it's a very like a new chapter in my
long life that I feel like I've already
had and you know I'm very excited about
it it's I'm nervous and scared and
um you know there's just so many things
to think about and uh you know it's just
but it's just like a wonderful process
to go through and and just like
what it does like first of all
let me just tell you this
Guantanamo Bay
it should be run by women in their first
trimester because then everything
they'll get all the information you know
what I mean dudes will be in there like
okay I'll tell you all the secrets and
there's a lot the laundry is in the
dryer and what do you want from Tito's
Taco you know what I mean they would get
everything they need they want out of
prisoners because it's a lot like wow
women go through a lot uh kudos to all
women out there all mothers anybody
that's gone through this process anybody
that's gone through a miscarriage and
this kind of thing which is something
else that is so much more common than
people like to talk about because it's
kind of thing where people blame
themselves and this but it's so much
more common than you even realize nature
is like hey this ain't gonna work we're
moving on
um you know some people deal with it in
different ways you know they take it in
like oh my God we had a life that you
know what happened it's like no it's
just this whole process is alive what it
does for women what it does to women and
what they go through the sickness and
and the physical transformation I'll
just say this if God is a woman that
[__] don't like women you know what I'm
saying
it's crazy so anyways
that's it so we're here you know
um you know so stay tuned man stay tuned
through you know beginning of the
podcast um we're gonna continue to talk
about the journey then we'll get Rachel
on to uh really go into detail all right
let's go into comments it's comment time
you know what I need to I need to
actually put like a uh something on the
screen when it's comment time but you
know I'm still working on this
um let's see another Matt Rife episode
from episode 23 people still going back
to look at Matt Rife episode I'm pretty
sure he's um who said this Cara bear6259
I'm pretty sure he's a millennial looked
it up definitely a millennial like God
they just people just love this kid man
uh common fool three two four zero I
don't know what that I don't know what
this is about but he said funny how the
biggest haters never have any cyber
security
[Laughter]
I don't know what that means if that's a
threat who knows
um
let's see what is this talking about
all right
himo gen man ma Gemma
what is this
I don't know this is a [__] dumb ass
name
hemorrhagenema
6416 there's no YouTube algorithm
there's only Google's AGI they just
presented it as being being an algorithm
it's been learning from millions of
users for years now it decides to hide
dislikes it determines viewable traffic
what's really wild it is it's probably
20 years old devs is coming okay I don't
know what that means but I guess yeah I
guess like what is the algorithm you
know there's a lot of talk of
suppression and stuff right now you know
you see YouTube taken down
Theo's podcast that he had with Roseanne
Barr
it's really crazy like she makes a joke
in the thing and people are clipping
that and putting that out like it's hate
but if you see the whole context of what
she says it it shouldn't be taken like
that but you know when you've had
previous issues uh all of your words are
being looked at it a certain way so you
know if you've gotten trouble before
people are like well you don't get the
benefit of the doubt anymore I don't
think that's right but I think that's
what's going on here and they took that
episode down and suspended his account
listen if that's what's happening right
now with YouTube they're they're coming
with this like what I believe is
censorship and if this isn't the
platform for Comics to be able to like
talk and stuff without this being some
sort of agenda going on man that's tough
it's tough because
there's like a mythical who's in charge
you know
um you know Elon Musk Buy on Twitter he
kind of shattered whatever our thoughts
were about Twitter actually ruined it in
my opinion so far but you know you ruin
things to make it better so we'll see
what the future holds for him but like
everything he's done so far is just like
and now we know that it's about just him
the mythicalness of the like the the
Enchantment of Twitter and who you
think's behind the scenes now that
there's a face to it we're just kind of
like ah I don't know he took the
specialness away with the the check blue
check mark because now if you have a
blue check we know you bought it and
that means it ain't special
like it don't prove anything the
specialness of it don't mean anything it
just means that are you paying for this
service now as opposed to it being about
oh well the the this mythical office of
YouTube has decided to you know check in
on this person and we're saying that is
that person here's a blue check mark we
verify that they are somebody you know
and it was something to strive for so
now
I think that it's a stigma to it so now
if you have a blue check people are like
oh okay look at this guy like it's he
totally I think that backfired you know
so but anyways thanks for the comment
um
let's see
Adrian 8788 said I sub but I never catch
it live but but
I comment to help out with the algorithm
thank you I appreciate that
uh
let's see
let's see YouTube what this guy said oh
this is another Matt Rife comment
YouTube music 5210 said you have to
remember Eric that the key difference
between older women and younger girls is
experience okay
I don't know what that means I guess if
I as if people don't know that but thank
you for your comment whatever that's
about
uh
let's see this uh an abyss seven King
284 set talks all this about Cod yet
still plays no I said right in the thing
that I'm still gonna play I don't think
I don't think boycotting the game is
going to help anything
I don't think it's gonna boycott to help
anything I still I think it's a great
game I'm still gonna play uh that
company made a huge mistake when it
comes to like the Nick Merk's issue but
you know people like that think they're
making a point like the like I would
love to watch this person I would love
to see this person writing that comment
and watching them be like this oh yeah I
got him you know what I mean it's like
that's just out of context not really
listening to the thing trying to make a
dumb point but I read the comments so
dumb Point made it obviously doesn't
really bother me because I'm I'm saying
it right here so but I get it everybody
has their opinion
um
okay let's see
somebody Fox
roxy2264 I came from the golden podcast
but I adore how he talks about her she
seems like a really silly goose here yes
she is she's talking about Rachel all
right
um let's see oh somebody oh you know
what this guy Corey was like what too
many comments but this one's a big one
he goes Eric this film this was filmed
years ago like you said but it also
takes place then to it's all before
James gunstuff the first James Gunn
Universe movie is Superman Legacy this
is still all spider-verse stuff that's
why Wonder Woman and everyone else is
still in it also the back in time stuff
was figured out the Justice League
Snyder cut you have to see that for this
to make sense that's how the movie ended
flash Save the World by going back in
time it was only a second or two though
in The Flash movie he learned to push it
further
and then everybody gets mad when I say
Henry because caviesel or whatever his
name is whatever the guy's name is you
know who I'm talking about
sick of you guys getting on me about
names and
um Supergirl killed that role too I
loved her stuff I understand people not
liking it but but for me it was a super
entertaining yeah I mean what I'm saying
is it wasn't a great movie and I already
know all this stuff that you're saying I
said it in my podcast you know James
Gunn
is trying to Hype up Disney Studios dumb
Disney DC Studios that's why he said it
was the greatest superhero movie I've
ever seen he lied
he lied it is not it isn't even I mean I
don't even Captain America won and I
thought that was terrible was better
than this movie okay
flash was just a mess all right and all
I'm trying to say about
the the science in the flash was shoddy
it wasn't like I don't believe it
and then like what kind of Stu what kind
of laboratory are they in were they
using mayonnaise jars
full of chemicals in front you know what
I mean like all that stuff was like this
is dumb
it just seemed dumb and then going back
in time
listen how they presented it
was trash that's all I'm saying
like I couldn't suspend my disbelief
with how they presented it okay that's
all that's all I was trying to say all
right anyways moving on y'all moving on
Moving on but thank you for all the
comments and you know leave comments and
I will read them uh let me go here
all right yeah thanks for all the people
that are live thanks for all the super
chats appreciate you guys uh for doing
you know for doing that viewer activity
let's see who we got here Janine uh as
always thank you you're you're my
favorite
um Mike uh in in West Palm Beach been a
member now for 34 months dude thank you
I appreciate you you can also be a
YouTube member guys so check that out so
all right so let's get into the uh
episode
you know what actually before we get
into the episode how about this guys
let's talk about a sponsor of the show
doordash doordash app code rwg summer
rwg summer all right summer is just
around the corner it's here now actually
uh after a happy July 4th for everyone
for us and from door and from doordash
you know and it's like summer doordash
pass get your dash pass from doordash
with the dash pass membership you can
save big I have it you can save big now
through July 19 you can buy things now
like swimsuits Beach snacks sunscreen
and more I mean it's just like a helpful
partner in your life that's helping you
do stuff you go to the market you forget
some stuff boom you don't have time to
go to the market you can get some stuff
maybe you need just some Tylenol you're
not feeling well maybe you need like a
couple of things you're going on a trip
or maybe you're going to the beach boom
here you are you can get all the stuff
that you need it's finally time for and
then look it's time for pool parties
backyard barbecues Outdoor Adventures
and sometimes the last minute you forget
stuff doordash is here for you with
Summer dash pass you'll enjoy zero
delivery fees and reduce service fees on
all eligible orders making it easier and
more affordable than ever to stock up on
all your favorite summertime Essentials
but that's not all y'all you also get
access to thousands of offers Nationwide
ensuring that this summer is one of the
one to remember all right so
experience in summer like no other
best your best summer with the dash pass
membership from door Dash today sign up
for doordash now and you'll get your
first month free free plus when you use
our promo code get 50 off up to ten
dollar value and you spend 15 or more on
your next door dash pass order when you
download the door Dash app and enter
riffin with Griffin nope rwg summer one
word rwg summer
that's 50 off when you spend ten dollars
or more on your next dash pass order
when you download the doordash app and
enter code Griffin
rwg summer rwg summer y'all that's rwg
summer don't forget code rwg summer for
50 Cent off your next order subject to
change terms apply
thank you doordash I haven't done an ad
in a while so that was great all right
um where we at now
okay so let's uh all right let me see
here
first crazy story up is man let's chalk
this under the too soon category too
soon
so some Subway in Georgia they had this
uh picture up you know
our subs don't implode
oof
too soon man we just we're so sensitive
now in a world that and in this case
it's like you know how people use their
sensitivity it is what it is man but
this is just one of those jokes that's
like it was a national story
you know
lives were lost
this is like when I don't know if you
guys remember when the space shuttle
exploded alive on television we're
watching and then like immediately some
of the jokes I saw were NASA need
another Seven astronauts that's one of
the I remember that joke like came out
right away and it was just like oof but
there was no social media back then so
this is a pre-social media joke like
there was no social media this would
just be out there and there would be no
outlet for people that get easily
offended or for people who just are
offended to just go out and Galvanize
and be like we need to burn all the
Subways down and they need to be taken
off the planet uh you know they should
not exist anymore because they made this
you know
tasteless joke you know it's kind of
thing where you make the joke and you go
all right come on guys really too soon
uh but let me get a tuna on wheat you
know what I mean it's like it's that
there's a way to handle it but you know
I'm not mad at the people that are mad
at this and I'm not even mad at Subway
but this is just a too soon it's a poor
it's a listen let's just be a 100 some
people this is funny okay like if you if
you take the like the thought that who
the people are
the the information you have in your
head there is a part of this that's like
okay I get how this it's a funny joke
right to some if you're into dark humor
you know like not everything has to have
a meaning it's just some dark humor but
then you have people like we live in a
world now where we're so interconnected
everybody's feelings are so important
like everybody is their feelings are the
most important thing in the world and
then you have people that are like
actually connected to these people who
are just like oof I don't want to see
that right so it's it's very nuanced
it's a lot going on here there are
people that it's black and white for
some people but not for me because I'm a
comic so I get it
I get why they thought this was funny I
get why they thought this was funny I
get why they thought people would look
at this and be like oh okay okay give me
a tuna and then I get also why people
are like what
people are dead why are you I get both
sides of this so just one of those weird
we'll chalk that under too soon baby too
freaking soon okay what are you doing
all right let's get rid of that story
what we got next here
um okay this one was just this this is
just the weirdest
this is the weirdest thing ever man let
me give me get this prepared so you guys
can really see all right
so this is one of them this is my what
segment
all right Ms
CHF
microscopic bag smaller than a grain of
salt sells for sixty three thousand
seven hundred fifty dollars
what
how much
a bag
smaller than a grain of salt
sold for 63
000 dollars
I mean
I thought Rachel was crazy with her bag
obsession
I've already bought her like three bags
you know like she loves these little
purses and stuff she already got I
already got her a little purse that was
like three thousand dollars a little
burst
nothing can even go in it
what are you paying sixty three thousand
dollars for for what is it for the
craftsmanship is it for like man you
where do you put it
like imagine who's that for
you know you got your you know are you
gonna be like uh how much is it
oh six dollars okay hold on a second
my my bag I got it I gotta look it I
gotta get my bag hold on like how do you
what what goes in there
maybe you only put salt in it see you at
the restaurant and you're like oh yeah I
got no sauce I got my own salt
a piece of salt
like what are you what are we talking
about I guess you're just paying for the
art of it it'll make no sense to me like
I
the things this is just when rich people
have money
and they don't know what to do with it
and they go oh you know what I'm gonna
buy this and they're just like oh look
what an Impulse Buy
like the dude didn't made this
he must be like imagine he got that call
right
you got like his art broker
yeah or I made this bag and they got
where is it it's right there you don't
see it it's like you just see what you
can do and he calls him he's like dude
somebody's going it was an auction and
you're getting 63 000. he's like what
now he's like in the factory now in the
factory he's on his desk making bags and
like he's gonna make like here's a you
know here's a wallet here's a like what
are we talking about
it's just this it's it's so ridiculous
like somebody in the chat said money
laundering I think so
this is this
did some some money laundering stuff how
you money launder how do you clean money
you know so you got some dirty drug
money and then some you you find an
artist who makes [__] and then you
go oh my God I oh is it a little bag oh
my God little bags are my thing and then
you take your you know your drug money
and you
you buy you know you go into into art
dealership or something and you somehow
your money is clean through this process
you know and it's dudes in on it he's
getting a percentage he getting a
thousand dollars because it would have
taken like what
how long does it take him to make this
little microscopic bag
it's crazy
on this line in this vein of like crazy
ass purchases
this one of my Instagram topics today
is the it's it's on the same it's on the
same line man
you know good old Biebs man Biebs
remember nfts guys
remember nfts
I don't even know what the hell they are
and he bought this nft for 1.3 million
on and now it's only worth 59 000.
what
so
this is just one of those things that
just didn't take off
remember like The nft Craze everybody
was like oh nft is going to be the new
way it's going to be the new thing this
is how we're gonna sell our digital art
because
the internet makes everything like you
know digital photography you know how do
you say you own something it's like well
I have it you know like we all own this
nft because you just take a picture of
it you can print it on your great
printer
and then you put it in a poster and you
put it on the wall there it is right
there
the the this is one of those things that
they try to manufacture something
they tried to manufacture hype and they
convinced people like this who have
money that they don't know what to do
with
and they were like yeah purchase this
for a million dollars thinking that oh
nfts is one of those Technologies that's
never going to go away and so in 10
years it's gonna be like you know the
Mona Lisa nah man this was dumb this is
dumb okay
real art you have to be able to
your senses
have to be able to
be affected by it right that's one of
the prerequisites of it right
it has to be something
that you can physically touch
or control
so like if you own the rights to a movie
you know you could decide all right I
own the rights to this movie so before
anybody else can watch it or look at it
they gotta pay you for that okay
and even that's a little tricky now with
how
the internet is working
but this thing
you have to believe that it's art first
of all this like monkey picture
and then you have to believe that like
these equations on the internet whatever
the numbers are that you say this is
some kind of you know you you have a
little whatever the hell it is man I
Somebody explain it to me in the
comments what the hell the nft is why is
it special like why is it significant
that you own this piece of code because
that's what it is right you're saying I
own the code but this is the visual
thing
that if I see it
that's what makes it art so you go to a
museum and you go watch the you see the
Mona Lisa and there's something about
that kind of art because you know oh
that's the real painting that the real
person made and there it is physically
there that's something that would be
worth millions of dollars right
but if you had
just like so many pictures of it
duplicate like replicas
are there why would the replicas be
I don't dude I'm my I can't even keep a
straight my my mental thought about this
I find it so crazy we got duped how
about that let me just end this topic
with
we all got fooled into thinking this is
like betamax man this is like a type of
technology that we thought oh this is
gonna be the next thing man and it was
like it's not it's never gonna this is
never gonna be a thing it's never gonna
be a thing okay nfts are never going to
be a thing no one cares why would you
care what like we we tried to make
people care you know it was like this
it didn't work
but the fact that this guy even could
get like the only reason why this 1.3
million dollar whatever it is is even
worth sixty thousand dollars is because
he owned it so now you could be like
yeah you pay sixty thousand dollars to
say I own that thing that this dude paid
a million dollars for can you believe it
so the value is in that not even in the
thing
it's not even
it's still he makes it valuable I don't
get it
if anybody can explain nfts to me in the
comments I will read it next week and be
like this person explained to me why
it's valuable and I know there's young
people out there young techie people who
are like no man you don't understand
you're old nfts are the future
I I you need to explain it to me
we're we don't care about this little
piece of code this little piece of thing
where it says hey that piece of art is
literally this it makes no sense because
there it is you can just Google
you know unless unless they had a way
where like
anytime you Google this image
it was always like Blurry anytime you
Google this image it had like a
watermark on it and there was no way to
see it clear
that's the technology was so Advanced
then I would be like well okay so the
only way to see this is through him
and you have to pay him or whatever it
is
other than that what the hell are we
talking about nfts man one of the that
that's this is one of the craziest it's
so crazy man
all right what's another one of my uh
Instagram stories this week
I don't know if y'all saw this
but isn't this your fear every time you
go to an amusement park back even back
in the day even when I was a kid I was
like is this safe
now there's a certain thing in society
where we feel like like this is like
a traffic light should work
like
you can't have a traffic light
both sides be green on some kind of
glitch that's one of those things that
that can never happen
taking a picture of this cracked roller
coaster would be like getting to an
intersection where this both stop signs
were taken down or both lights were
green you would see that and be like oh
[__] this is dangerous
it's one of those things that you think
never happened it's like this should
never be when you get to the airport and
you see a plane with like the engine is
about to fall off of it there's like a
certain level of Competency that we
think
stuff certain things should have
amusement parks are one of those places
man
when you go to an amusement park this is
a place predominantly for children and
we are putting the safety of our
children
on this piece of
engineered you know it's this this piece
of awesome engineering this this like
you know aerodynamic sort of like
whatever the science of it is and we
think okay y'all got it's safe right
like it's not even it's a presumption of
safety if the Park is open the
[__] is safe that's how we think
we walk into a roller coaster like it's
just like this man when you walk into an
office building this would be this was
the equivalent to this too you walk to
an office building right and for some
reason the door opens and you don't see
the elevator yet but you see the cable
is unraveling
it's that kind of thing you'd be like
what
the elevator there's a certain level
that
of things that like they always gotta
work and when they don't work you put a
sign up out of order
that's just how when we walk into an
office building we want this [__] to
work period we don't even think about it
we don't think hey is this elevator been
checked recently nah you the door is
open you get in and you go up 100 Floors
you're dangling above your whole life is
at risk in this moment but you never
think about it that's how you think
about roller coasters when you go to a
roller coaster man you think to yourself
oh they just they got there's no way
this isn't gonna be safe because there's
kids just people's lives are at risk man
you look at that does that not look
crazy to you this big ass crack in this
roller coaster and this guy this was
really this one really gets me about
this roller coaster shutdown after man
on social media discovers deadly crack
discovers
this [__] is in plain sight it's not
like he discovered like a little crack
and he was like yo this might turn into
something like those little cracks on
your windshield it's not like you in
somebody's car and you go wait hold on a
second what what is uh hey dude you got
a little crack in your roller in your um
windshield it's gonna you know oh man oh
I didn't even see that
who didn't see this what are we talking
about
this crazy this is crazy now I think I
have a I think I have a video of it too
oh here we go here we go here we go
um where is it what is this is this it
no I don't know what this is
oh I don't wait let me let me I gotta
oh here we go here we go here we go look
at this
the crack's already there y'all oh wait
wait you know what I gotta do like this
oh you know what we gotta go like this
change the website look
boom and then we'll go like this
I mean
what dude what wait oh who's this chick
that's so fat they they're going too
fast with this but anyways
yeah
I don't know what to say
you know
I mean what are we talking about
I mean the fact that that's a thing
like you you got it
it makes you now question everything
I mean question everything now right
like you're going You're Going to the
amusement park now and you're looking at
the thing like okay let's
um
let's like take a look at this you when
you want to walk up to the front be like
yeah can I see the inspection when's the
last inspection it will be like every
time you got into an elevator you had to
do that you know how they always have in
the elevator it says
um the the elevator the the the the
papers for the elevator or in the
manager's office or whatever it is like
that it's like you went to get an
elevator be like yeah can I see the
papers maybe you don't want to see that
because you'll realize oh they haven't
actually haven't checked these cables in
10 years or whatever it is like that so
this roller coaster I believe let's see
an amusement park in in North Carolina
this is in North Carolina
that's a big ass crack man
you imagine that that sucker
the roller coaster goes on it this could
have been a super duper tragedy so
yeah that was weird
in the
your wife this is for the women out
there the this goes to your when your
wife says I told you so
new study finds unwashed pillowcases
contain
times more bacteria than toilet seats
just let that sink in
let that sink in y'all and
000 more bacteria than a toilet seat
wash your pillowcase
okay
wash your pillowcases
go into your room right now pause the
pot you listening to the podcast are you
headed home you in the car wherever you
at right now when you get home
take the pillowcase off your pillow and
put that [__] in the wash
that's all
that's all we're going to say about this
shout out to Rachel for
been telling me about this from when we
first met
oh man all right so in weird Tech news
and then I'll get into Indiana Jones
it's not even weird techno I think
actually I do think it's kind of weird I
don't know if you guys heard about this
NASA Mission they're doing so Master
NASA is locking four science nerds into
into total isolation for a year so it's
as if like you're gonna be on this in
this like bunker that we're gonna
simulate Mars conditions to see if you
can
deal with like if we send people to Mars
I don't know is it worth it
I mean it's going to Mars
is that is that the thing that we really
want to go to Mars but imagine you being
someone that wants to go to Mars
yeah but like I don't know if this works
I would almost have a group of
scientists put all these guys through
the rigors of space travel right you
don't even tell them you know you tell
them this is a secret mission you lie to
them the whole step of the way okay you
lie to them every step of the way you
lie to these people you have an
underground Silo bunker something that
you know like Truman Show you know you
got like a fake whatever it is some kind
of Dome fake thing
and you tell these people they going to
Mars you fake the whole thing
because then you would really see if
these people can handle it
because to me there's something in your
mind that you know just a door I can get
out of here
unless you also signed up you told them
look
we don't care what happens
we're never opening this door
okay this is what you're signing up for
so sign on the dotted line here that
once you go inside here and we close
this door
it cannot be open for a year no matter
what
so if somebody only are dying here make
sure y'all bury him we got a little
cemetery plot over here but other than
that none of y'all getting out like it
has to be like that
then you would get like a real
indication of
how people can handle themselves in this
situation
because first of all even just to travel
like they need to keep them in like a
little space thing a fake spaceship for
like however long it takes to get to
Mars so you got to be in this thing for
six months can you imagine being on like
a Spirit Airline flight for six months
because that's about right how big it is
I mean I don't know this just this whole
thing sounds crazy it's something that I
would never want to do I'm one of these
people that's like get the space travel
[__] down pat where you know it's we
teleported you know or we like on the
Enterprise and it's like you know what I
mean like a cruise ship at this point go
to Mars on you know Carnival Mars trip
or whatever but this kind of stuff I
don't know I don't know if I have it in
me to do this what do you guys think
could you do this do you could you care
about something so much that you would
like be a part of this experiment for a
year a year
a year
crazy
all right y'all let's get into
uh what today's episode
no spoilers in this right now y'all
we're not gonna have no spoilers
Okay so
wait what's going on here
oh you know I always have to do it like
this for some reason
yeah I had to go to that for some reason
Tango this all right guys the new indie
Anna Jones movie is out
the final installment of the Indiana
Jones well I think the final installment
of Harrison Ford as Indiana Jones uh
this one's called Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny
uh and let me say this so as I as I said
before I I have some patreon content
ideas there's YouTube YouTube subscriber
and twitch subscriber ideas so right
after this I'm gonna go on to Eric
Griffin gaming it's gonna be just talk
and I'm going into spoiler details on
Black Mirror and a little bit about this
movie the plot of this I might go into
this but I'm not sure yet but for sure
we're going to do black mirror and
that's going to be some new fresh
patreon contents YouTube subscriber
twitch subscriber content so but anyways
I want to go see Indiana Jones and I'll
just say this it wasn't terrible okay
it wasn't it's not the best movie in the
series
um to me that's still the first one I
mean I just I think if I had to rank
the Indiana Jones movies I would say
Raiders of the Lost Ark number one
Temple of Doom the second one number two
actually in the order that they even
they came out actually to I thought
number three
and then the one with Sean Connery as
his father those are those are three
solid Standalone movies and then it just
gets kind of wonky when he's like way
older and then they got Shia LaBeouf in
it and then this one dial of Destiny
um yeah I mean little personal story
about Indiana Jones is when I was a
because this the original Indiana Jones
came out and I believe 80 something oh
man right I mean this is it's crazy how
long ago
uh this movie came out uh yeah here we
go Indiana Jones let me see when did
this original movie come out 81 y'all in
81 I was nine
that's wow right because I'm born 72
yeah
yeah man
when I was so I'm nine years old
right and my mom is like we're going to
a movie and my mom's name is Sandra and
she and she had a friend named Sandra so
we're like they're like in love with
Harrison Ford okay so they come to me
I'm a little I'm nine years old you know
my mom's single parent she's like we're
going to the movies I go well we seeing
I'm so excited she goes we're gonna go
see this movie called Indiana Jones
Furious listen to me Furious I mean I
was a pouty little brat like I want to
see this dumbass movie Indiana Jones I
know what that means
so we go to this movie
I gotta tell you
when I left that movie I wanted a hat a
leather jacket and a whip and I was
running around the living room jumping
from I was jumping from couch all over
the place in my head just going
had an extension cord trying to whip
things I was trying to swing through I
mean that movie it was one of the most
impactful
greatest movie experiences I've had in
my entire life was watching Indiana
Jones with my mom and her friend as a
nine-year-old
and I was like it just the only thing I
I tell you there's
two other movie experiences I think that
are equivalent to it I'll give you three
the next one would be Jurassic Park when
I saw the dinosaurs
for the first time that that CGI was so
spectacular that we were like in the
theaters like wow this is the this is
what movies are going to be moving
forward you know that was spectacular
and Aladdin when I saw the Aladdin
cartoon I must have saw it like nine
times in the theater I just loved that
movie I loved Robin Williams and and and
just like the comedy of it and the music
and everything I was like this this is
great those are like significant movies
oh and the other one was Return of the
Jedi watching Return of the Jedi with my
mom again watching Return of the Jedi
and then like hearing THX sound for the
first time with that surround sound in
the theater that was the first time they
introduced that and just and just like
them like being old enough to like
really like being like wow people are
really into this because I I don't even
remember watching Star Wars or or like
Star Wars was like 77 or something like
that I was like so young and Empire
Strikes Back you know you have to be
like is that such a heady movie so
you're like all right what is this but
Return of the Jedi I was like oh wow
this is like you felt like you were a
part of something so those were some
really great movie experiences but
Indiana Jones you you know and so seeing
Harrison Ford this iconic person man
Harrison Ford has been three of the most
iconic movie characters Han Solo Indiana
Jones and Jack Ryan
like
unbelievable okay and then he's been in
some really great movies along his
career Harrison Ford has had a fantastic
career he had a great run as Indiana
Jones but
it's over y'all it's over
yeah you guys tell me your uh Movie
experience tell me uh what movies that
you like you know when you saw it you
were like wow this is incredible
somebody said Jaws I would agree Jaws
but I was like that was so terrifying
that you know man I have scary stories
about movies and maybe I'll talk about
that another time but yeah but it's over
for Indiana Jones Harrison Ford
my big takeaway from this is he's old
you know what I mean
it's like yeah your grandpa shouldn't be
running around trying to punch people
and and they would and then the thing
about this movie too is there was a lot
of
the first part of the movie is like AI
CGI young version of Harrison Ford on an
adventure that we didn't know about type
of thing and then now it's like like you
know then we're jumping ahead to this so
that part of it was very interesting
but you know you saw it and you were
like
like that CGI was way better than the
flash like there was some CGI and Flash
where you were like this is trash when
he was doing the the Dual playing two
characters playing himself right and
there were some times where you could
clearly see oh this is like a CGI
version uh in this movie the whole all
of it was CGI like in terms of like the
hair the Harrison Ford character on the
screen was a young version of him and as
you can see even in this picture I have
behind me of like you know look how his
age he's aged great this is my [__]
80 80 years old looks great looks
fantastic but his Action Hero days are
over and you know it didn't feel like
Indiana Jones movie honestly you know it
was like times when he was a grumpy old
man in it a lot which is like I get it
that's the character he's playing now
and this is what's happened in his past
and I just I wasn't attached to the
story the way I would have liked I think
that they there were some blunders in
the in the plot in terms of like
suspending your disbelief with this
woman in the in the movie
um
uh what's her name Phoebe Walter Bridge
she stars as Helena you know she's like
the heroine in the movie but she does
something in the movie that I'm like
terrible like she her character did
something terrible I can just I don't I
was like oh you can't just let that go
how can you just let that go she left
you to die sort of thing you know so I
don't know there's a lot of it you know
and then like Antonio Banderas is in it
for a second they brought back that guy
that played Salah in the movies you know
uh John I can't I'm not gonna mess his
name up but he looked old as hell it's
just a reminder of how old the movie was
and then they brought back Karen Allen
again who she doesn't really even act
anymore this is the only character I
believe she's ever played Just Marion
and Indiana Jones and she was fantastic
in it and and it was a very sweet homage
to the original movie in this at the end
which I actually teared up I actually
teared up because I just but I think
it's because of my own personal
connection to Indiana Jones so
um I don't know man it was
you know
I don't know you know what I mean
it's it's hard to like really
um
it's hard to really like I don't wanna
like again I don't want to trash the
movie because it's like he deserves a a
a a a send-off you know and and a lot of
times too it's like it's hard to like
the thing about archeology in a movie is
it has to be olden times to me you know
because
how is [__] not discovered at this point
you know like how we not finding tombs
is there anything still left to find
maybe there is maybe I gotta Google it
and see like what's the most recent
archaeological find well actually they
did find that sword recently that I saw
like last week they found some ancient
sword so yeah I mean I'm sure they're
still finding little Trinkets and things
like that but like Indiana Jones is
about finding like a a big ass Temple
that's like somehow nobody knew where
this was you know you know what I mean
like so if if we're talking about the
Indiana Jones in 2023 you know so
you know it's it's very interesting uh I
I thought it was entertaining you know
but I wouldn't give it more than six
woo-woos
[Music]
so there you go guys
there you go
um so anyways that's uh that's it for
this Today's Show we're from with
Griffin let me know let me get my music
going because you know what we do next
you know so like again I suggest that
you uh
subscribe
you know what I mean subscribe to the
show hit the notifications so you can
you can always know what's when I'm
going live on Wednesday you know be a
part of that
um
let me see what what am I gonna
oh is this one right here so be a part
of that and then you know twitch live
which I'm about to go live on Twitch in
about five minutes I'm gonna go live on
Twitch Eric Griffin gaming
uh and I'm gonna do an in-depth review
of Black Mirror each episode gonna take
me like maybe 20 minutes or so and
that's going to be some new content that
I'm going to put up on my patreon and
it's going to be subscriber only on
Twitch and then on also on my YouTube on
my YouTube channel here just for members
so if you want to watch it live it'll be
there and I'm gonna pick a different day
to do it but I'm doing it today just so
you guys can be aware of that so as I
said and then it'll be up on patreons if
you want to be a patreon member to you
know be a part of getting the extra
content from everyone Griffin and I
would and I would love
and that support would be you know
greatly appreciated guys but anyways you
know what time it is
oh it's time for the rap recap
with the old man
[Music]
you could even clap
along to the song
they never do it wrong
I can't call jumping around like I'm
Donkey Kong
uh Indiana Jones
it was pretty good
I wish you would
come see it
just a bit
nine years old
jumping around
that's what I was told
get a little purse
in a little little verse
oh oh
nft
[Music]
cause I don't see
one of that
thank you for watching Richard Griffin
I'm always sniffing
got a big nose
everybody knows cause it grows
and it shows
oh check out these flows
everybody knows
thanks for watching y'all
get on there Griffin gaming Erica for
gaming on Twitch
in about five minutes and we're gonna go
if you want to go into depth if you want
spoilers on Black Mirror that's what
it'll be
whoa thank you y'all
and I will see you
next week
[Music]